okay so I'm at the ATM trying to get 20
bucks to get us some coffee and it spits
out this piece of paper that says funds
not available so I'm like I don't think
so and the guy who lives under the
envelope table starts giggling at
me anyway I stick my card back in and
this time it eats my card and tells me
that I am thousands of dollars overdrawn
thousands so no C
[Laughter]
coffee no no coffee no ATM card no money
and the worst part of it is that the
bank has me on video going like this
what God
thank how could this happen it must be
an explanation well now I just cashed
all those little checks you've been
giving me could that be it
look Jack There Goes My World there goes
my everything you stop worrying she's
just a maid just a
maid that's like saying that Pras are
just shoes or vodka is just a morning
beverage oh sorry I'm late oh God that
sounded insincere I'm late
Karen
Karen yeah I'm up I'm up Stan get off of
[Laughter]
me where am
I Karen you are at work it's 10:30 in
the morning and because you seem to
believe that fabric can be sent over
phone
lines I now owe this guy 150 bucks for a
service
call oh my my God it's 10:30 honey why'd
you let me sleep so late I got to get
out of
here there's a needle full of botulism
with my forehead's name written all over
it can't believe I'm at a public pool
why doesn't somebody just pee directly
on me look at all of these Stan has been
so good to me honey oh and all of the
sweet memories they bring
back on my knees and
[Laughter]
[Applause]
B oh on my back in
IRA and then there was that time in
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Nantucket Good Times well good jewels
anyway oh look car stands well do you
have a wh honey why do I need a wh I'm
going to live forever that is the deal
isn't it red Dan put me on a budget oh
that
word I guess it was that hat that I
bought last week that pushed him over
wait Stan got upset because you bought a
hat Well the hat was in Geneva and it
wasn't really a hat it was a ski
lodge everything that's been going on
with me lately Stan staying in prison me
all alone in the house with 16 servants
most of whom don't even jump anymore
when I shoot at their
feet well your news really gives me
something to smile about what are you
doing I'm looking for tissues I'll have
your assistant get them for you she's
late again oh fire her already I'm not
going to fire Karen her social contacts
keep my business afloat why does she
even work I mean isn't she she worth
like a gazillion dollars she feels
working keeps her down to earth I know
I'm late my driver had another bronchial
incident that was disgusting I had to
raise the partition but that's no excuse
I should be punished I'm writing you a
check Karen tell Grace she should fire
you Grace tell Will to redirect his
anger at his mother where it
belongs call me later bye all right
there you go guilt be
gone Karen I don't want a check I want
assistance I'm the boss I give you
checks yes you do honey and I love them
I do you know I keep them all right here
in this
box Lord look at this place we're 3
seconds away from being mugged or
pierced Karen would you stop worrying
nothing's going to harm you not while
I'm
around uh-oh
nothing's going to harm you not while
I'm
around oh good now I feel safe you'll
frighten him away with an Angela
Lansbury
bad hey what what's going on what's
happening what's with the TV oh I'm
watching what I would call the feel-good
movie of my
life did you rent pretty women
again come on give it up honey the only
thing you two haven't common is horse
teeth and bad taste in
men you're a filthy little
[Laughter]
[Applause]
piggy lordy lordy look at all the
freaks the rack you heard the expression
off the rack I know the expression stand
hands off the
rack B
bang even in the midwest I'm
funny come on honey this place is
dangerous I'm supposed to be Uptown
looking down on all of this I'm going
home oh Mr sister you are so
Fier 10 points for realness
baby well thank you ladies snap
snap he thinks you're a man he thinks
I'm a
Karen something you want to tell
me what that
me what's going on honey what's
happening why aren't you licking that
floor oh all right it is me but it's not
what you think really cuz I think it's
you and amaz uniform whipping some old
guy in a onesie Am I
Wrong come on it's just a little fetish
film oh my God how did this thing get
into
circulation oh my
God this is the end of me I don't think
I can go on Caren what are you doing
stop me Caren don't be ridiculous there
we go nice and
[Laughter]
cold
[Applause]
honey what's going on what's happening
what's all this
aboutone what's this what are you doing
who's that supposed to
be
ow
oh oh honey honey can we get a couple of
sear DOI salads with honey mustard on
the side I don't work here that wasn't
my question
was come on Jack we got to get out
of what are you looking at
sideburns never seen somebody with money
and
soap oh boy just one question is dirty
little pig boy the other white
come on spill it well I was just out of
college I was broke it's the oldest
story in the world Boy Meets Girl boy
wants girl to do dominatrix film girl
says naked boy says yeah girl says
forget it boy says okay then just wear
this rubber dress and beat the old guy
with a scrub brush girl says how
hard Stan hi honey it's me yes I'm at
designer markdowns in pamas uh-huh oh
the budget thing's fine yeah yeah I'm
just about to buy a rhinestone studded
track suit I thought I'd wear it when we
go boating with the
bronfman okay okay bye-bye stand sending
the
helicopter budget crisis
over okay grace buy yourself a little
ugly for work tomorrow I'll be on the
Roof oh look at me I'm drinking beer out
of a bag I'm so
bad Karen come on let's go we've already
missed the scary gay goblins listen to
her lady
complainer oh that's cute is that a drag
name oh I want a drag name give me a
drag name okay sugar here's how you do
it take the name of your first pet and
the First Street you lived on Sho
[Applause]
Fontana honey honey come here what would
your name be
um Glenn
125th come on come on break time is over
K I don't want to study anymore can I
just wing it tomorrow at immigration no
you have to convince them that you two
are a real married couple or this one's
going to be spooning Ceviche out of a
bucket on a Dusty soccer field back in
chimmy
chaville I find that appalling oh yeah
well I find stretch pants appalling but
I'm too much of a lady to mention it fat
ass hey honey wow I love your new
bag it's garbage thank God you said
it now kids ruin everything I mean look
at the stitching on this thing
huh you cannot trust a 10-year-old to do
a good hidden
button you have a very delightful
chuckle oh thank you they're real
too Lio
Banks Lio like the train Banks like
money and you
are Anastasia
beaverhousen Anastasia like Russian
royalty Beaver housing
like where the beaver
live IAM
might what brings you to this Lush
Paradise Miss Beaver how
oh I don't know really just killing time
I
suppose waiting for something good to
happen
interesting I was just doing the same
thing looks like my wait is
over well well where did you come from
Lionel did the smooth talking jiggalo
convention let out
early listen why don't we continue this
in my very comfortable Suite
upstairs I've got loads of cash so time
is no
issue Mr Banks you think I'm a
hooker body those clothes that
voice
yes well as flattered As I Am by that
I'm afraid I have to disappoint
you you don't have sex for money no I do
not we're Jewels for Furs for mixed
Securities like a
lady but for money how dare you watch
this and I can
steal can you walk through doors
no hey hey let me in let me
in
hello I didn't know there was a new maid
working on this floor what I've never
seen someone so beautiful how long have
you been working
here 2
weeks I just met the most incredible May
are you sure you just didn't lean into
the door knob
again no no he's like a dream like that
place I go to to work
engineering here to check the thermostat
oh that's it Rosie quick do I look as
bad as
[Music]
you what's going
on he thinks I'm a maid you have to
pretend you're me okay I'll take out my
heart and sell my soul to the
devil we don't have time for that here
put this on hurry
hurry okay oh
Mrs
Walker that's
right hi
there shut your mouth maid my jewelry
might fall
out what a
monster who taught her to talk to
another human being like
that I have no
idea listen lady in my country I was a
school
teacher
yeah well in this country you wash my
[Music]
bras list I can pick up you at
any oh Jack don't let him take my
sunshine away I love my
mom I'm Anastasia
beaverhousen why are you using your
Alias because I passed a couple of bad
checks here you know for
sport housing can you believe it me a
Banana Republic sales associate and my
guidance counselor said i' never amount
to
anything honey I'm so proud of you come
on let's go to Barney's there's a new
sales girl there and we got to get her
fired she has a great tooth come
on I can't I'm working hello well yeah
and I'm ovulating but nothing's going to
come of that
either you don't understand I have
responsibilities look a headset you know
this isn't working this is going to
interfere with our friendship I work a
40-hour month for what's her name and I
always make time for us come on I can't
all right but I promise nothing's going
to change between us hey I'll I'll come
over later and we'll short sheet
Rosario's
bed maybe we can take a big bubble bath
together nothing would give me more
pleasure than to sponge clean the beaver
housing Wilma Anastasia what your
version of sex huh what gets you too
excited the most
excited that would have to be without
question game night oh a night sounds
tedious you should do
that you know what you're right we
should it is so it's so fun every year
Joe and Larry and Robin Ellen come over
and we have this this big huge parlor
game blowout we play for the suck on it
cup God that's tragic what's
that it's a trophy and we call it the
suck on it cup because when you win and
will and I always
win you get to turn to the losers and
say suck on
it which lever do I pull to be crushed
by a
safe Grace it's Christmas for goodness
sake think about the baby
Jesus up in that Tower letting his hair
down
so that the three wise men can climb up
and spin the drele and see that there's
six more weeks of winter wait don't you
have will sperm oh dear lord
where in this bag please tell me that
you didn't drink your lunch yet honey I
just got done drinking breakfast you got
to give the liver a little time to
digest so it's it's okay oh cutie of
course it is come here
you you backstopping boy
you are never never to see her
again do you hear me you stay away from
that London hog or I'll put fish HS in
your nipples and fly you off the
Chrysler Building you got
that